foreign
everyone
first of all I would like to apologize
for the three-week absence
I was just taking a little break
the SCP we're going to be looking at
today is scp-4419
object class catter
special containment procedures
due to the expansive range of
circumstances in which scp-4419
manifestations occur containment efforts
are to focus on information control and
post manifestation cleanup rather than
physical imprisonment
any witnesses to an scp-4419
manifestation are to be dosed with a
Class B or Class A amnestic as
appropriate for their level of exposure
in cases where it is possible to restore
the bodies of scp-4419 victims to
roughly standard human configurations a
cover story is to be established to
explain any remaining damage as a result
of their original injuries in cases
where this is not feasible victims of
scp-4419 are to be brought into custody
and if possible euthanized
a cover story is then to be established
regarding the death of the victim due to
their original injuries or conditions
description
scp-4419 is a vehicle resembling an
ambulance of a varying make and model
which spontaneously appear in an area
shortly before a medical emergency
arises the means by which scp-4419
predicts these situations is currently
unknown although the appearance of
scp-4419 differs from manifestation to
manifestation it will always resemble an
ambulance appropriate for the local
culture
upon the occurrence of the medical
emergency
scp-4419 will proceed directly to the
injured individual Hereafter referred to
as the victim to individuals of varying
physical appearances in paramedic
uniforms will then exit from the back of
scp-4419 secure the victim and bring
them back with them into scp-4419 the
individuals that emerge from scp-4419
will behave as expected for a medical
professional in this situation but will
repel any attempt by others to prevent
them securing the victim via extreme
physical Force
once the victim has been secured within
scp-4419 it will leave the area at
extreme speeds disappearing the moment
it is outside of observation
two to seven days later the victim will
be returned outside a local area
suffering from extreme and invasive
bodily modifications although the
majority of these alterations would
logically result in the death of the
victim death will not occur in these
cases unless the modifications are
tampered with or otherwise undone the
specific nature of these modifications
differs from case to case although there
does appear to be a level of correlation
with the original medical emergency see
in counterlog 4419-1
in counter log 4419 1. the following is
a log of encounters with scp-4419 the
original medical emergencies in each
case and the bodily modifications
applied to the victim note that this log
does not encapsulate all known scp-4419
victims and a full record is available
upon request from The Dana archive at
site-31
date 0702 1983 medical emergency a
breaking car hits a pedestrian crossing
the street resulting in a broken leg
bodily modification victim returned with
all limbs amputated and relocated to
protrude directly from his torso limbs
were re-amputated and a cover story was
established to explain the loss of Limbs
as the result of a much more severe car
accident date 2311 1994 medical
emergency a man suffers from a broken
jaw following a fight outside a bar
bodily modification victim returned with
his jaw forced permanently open in
addition a glass window was installed in
the mouth to permit viewing of the heart
which had been relocated to the back of
their throat due to the relocation of
the heart reversion of the body
modifications was not possible and the
victim was euthanized date 1906 1999.
medical emergency a homeless man suffers
from a drug overdose bodily modification
victim returned to the same place he was
originally taken from the top of the
victim's skull had been removed and the
Brain crudely scooped out and placed
into the victim's hands which had been
fused together in front of him while
being brought into custody the victim's
brain fell out of his hands and he
instantly expired note that at no point
was the victim's brain actually
connected to his nervous system
date 2901 2003 medical emergency a wife
and husband involved in a car crash
suffer numerous broken bones and severe
bleeding bodily modification victims
returned fused together by their Banks
all bones that had been broken in the
original accident were meticulously
removed resulting in the loss of use of
some limbs the victims were successfully
separated administered amnestics as
appropriate in their modified limbs were
amputated date 1502 2006 medical
emergency an elderly man suffers from a
heart attack bodily modification victim
was returned with 11 additional
non-functional Hearts within his body
stuffed between his existing organs
exploration occurred when surgeons
attempted to remove these additional
Hearts before agents could arrive on the
scene the surgeons and medical staff who
had treated the victim were administered
amnestics and the body confiscated date
1909 2008 medical emergency a fire at a
bar results in 19 people suffering from
severe burns and additional seven people
suffer from Skull fractures and broken
bones when they attempt to confront the
individuals who emerge from scp-4419 and
are also taken as victims It is believed
existing injuries were exacerbated and
new injuries caused by attempting to
force 26 people into the limited space
within scp-4419 bodily modification
victims returned to the local community
center as a single watery Mass which
twitches and shivers when physical
contact is applied has no method of
euthanizing the victims could be found
they are currently stored in a liquid
tank at site-31 date 2411 2014 medical
emergency a U.S military private is shot
while on troll in Afghanistan bodily
modification due to the suspicious
nature of
scp-4419's arrival and the forceful
securing of the private other soldiers
on the patrol fire upon scp-4419 as it
leaves Witnesses report seeing a viscous
black fluid leaking from the resultant
bullet holes in scp-4419 surface the
victim is found broken down into a thin
paste and spread over the walls of their
Barracks the next day the agents who
initially secured The Remains reported
seeing a mostly intact eyeball dilate
when they approached what has been
brought into storage is referred to for
convenience sake as remains it is
currently not known whether or not the
victim has expired
again I apologize for the quality of my
voice today it's uh very strained as the
last section of my Hiatus I got a cold
[Laughter]
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
Timothy
anvil
zargaron
Professor Puffer
Spencer J telp
well rimmer
vinyl
givios the hollow
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
tailored printers
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
a real American Hebrew
the Morrigan
James Saba
and NJ vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you